TRYING TO EAT INFLUENCE TRYING
TO INFLUENCE.
>> Chris: FBI INFORMANT SAYS
RUSSIA ROUTED MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO THE U.S. IN AN EFFORT
TO BUY INFLUENCE WITH THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND WITH BILL AND
HILLARY CLINTON.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE EXPLAINS.
>> FOX NEWS CONFIRMS AN FBI
INFORMANT WHO HAS NOT GONE
PUBLIC SPENT FOUR HOURS ONCE
ANSWER QUESTIONS FROM STAFFERS
ON THE SENATE AS WELL AS HOUSE
OVERSIGHT AND INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEES.
THEIR FOCUS IS AN OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION DEAL THAT ALLOWED
A RUSSIAN NUCLEAR ENERGY AGENT
TO GAIN A CONTROLLING STAKE IN
URANIUM ONE.
CANADIAN-BASED COMPANY WITH
MINING INTEREST IN THE WESTERN
U.S.
>> EARLY 2010, THE FIX WAS IN.
>> THE FBI INFORMANT’S LAWYER
SAYS RUSSIANS LAID THE
GROUNDWORK AFTER BILL CLINTON
AND A WEALTHY CANADIAN FULL
PHILANTHROPIST WENT TO
KAZAKHSTAN.
HE SAID HE SOLD HIS STAKE BEFORE
THE DEAL WENT THROUGH AND 18
MONTHS BEFORE HILLARY CLINTON
BECAME SECRETARY OF STATE.
BY 20    2010, THE RUSSIANS MADR
MOVE.
>> AND HILLARY CLINTON BECAME
SECRETARY OF STATE, THAT’S WHEN
THE RUSSIANS WENT TO TOWN AND
SAID WE CAN GO IN THERE AND WE
ARE GOING TO GET THIS URANIUM
ONE BUSINESS DONE.
>> CLINTON DID NOT HAVE THE
FINAL SAY.
THE DEAL CONSIDERED BY THE
COMMITTEE ON FOREIGN INVESTMENT
IN THE UNITED STATES REQUIRED
APPROVAL FROM NINE DIFFERENT